monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre collègues le protocole appliqué
depuis lundi s'efforce de rendre l'école
plus agile et réactive à la situation
sanitaire une disposition cependant pose
problème elle impose en niveau 3 qu'en
l'absence d'un professeurs non remplacés
les enfants ne sont plus répartis dans
les autres classes ils ne sont tout
simplement plus accueillis à l'école
pour reprendre le choix lexical du
moment cette règle en mer de tous les
parents vacciner ou non pour chaque
absents 25 familles apprennent à 8h20
devoir garder leurs enfants la vie des
familles et précarisée la continuité
pédagogique et social rompu les parents
assigné à résidence ne peuvent
travailler l'économie est perturbée sans
claque au vide en soit nécessairement la
cause un canon pas d'école mais bien
réel un professeur n'a pas été remplacé
hier 25 familles sont impactés parmi
elles une assistante maternelle qui en
conséquence garde de ses enfants est
plus celui d'un enseignant qui reste
donc à la maison est né à son tour pas
remplacer 25 autres familles impact et
c'est sans fin avec 10 % d'absents
aujourd'hui potentiellement 30 % à la
fin du mois le phénomène va s'amplifier
je comprends monsieur le ministre
l'intention de limiter le brassage
néanmoins les mêmes enfants sont
mélangés en dehors de l'école en famille
lors des activités associatives ils le
sont aussi sur les temps périscolaires
malgré les règles de zonage d'horaires
malgré les tentatives de maintien en
groupe places mises en place par les
collectivités
quoi qu'il en soit la répartition dans
les autres classes et traçable bien sûr
le remplacement de chaque professeur
absent demeurer la meilleure solution
mais ce n'est pas nouveau peu d'absents
sont remplacés et toujours avec un temps
de latence les recrutements que vous
avez engagés porteront au mieux le taux
de 9 à 15 % des effectifs c'est loin de
répondre aux problèmes posés
immédiatement par le protocole je vous
sais soucieux de maintenir la continuité
pédagogique et l'école ouverte alors
monsieur le ministre quand allez-vous
supprimer cette règle de non accueil à
l'école des enfants dont les professeurs
absents ne sont pas remplacés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]